so welcome to today's webinar on
bioinformatics for precision medicine uh
so we know that Precision medicine is
actually changing the way we understand
diagnose and treat many diseases right
that also include cancer and this
transformation of the way that we treat
diseases is actually driven by high
throughput sequencing data that is high
throughput sequencing molecular data
that we get from patients for diagnosis
and prognosis purposes and for animal
models from animal models to actually
understand the understand the disease
that we are actually dealing with and we
can also perform a large scale cell and
experiments to ah characterize the
responses of different diseases and
specifically tumor also to several of
the treatment options that we have lined
up for them
so uh
to compare with Precision medicine
traditional medicine uses symptoms to
diagnose diseases and drugs to treat
these symptoms but Precision medicine
aims to turn this approach on its head
right Precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention that takes into account
individual variability in genes and
individual variability in environment
and different changes in the lifestyle
for each and every person
this approach or such an approach will
allow doctors and researchers to predict
more accurately which treatment and what
kind of prevention strategies are will
work for a particular disease and in
which groups of people it is expected or
it is understood to work better so this
is in complete contrast to one size
fits-all approach that is in which the
disease treatment and prevention
strategies are developed for an average
person with less and less consideration
for the individual variances and
individual differences
so after a lot of research we are poised
to enter a new era in the medical
practice where detailed genetic and
other molecular information about the
patient's disease is routinely used to
deploy effective and patient specific
remedies to treat it we are about to
enter the era of precision medicine
so the future of medicine is
increasingly driven by the availability
of data and the expansion and the
standardization of high throughput
sequencing that results in medical
practice that is both Ultra and Ultra
personalized and Ultra precise
extracting meaningful implications from
this data requires deep analytical
expertise and it also requires
integrating several of these data
several of these omics data from
different molecules so let's take a look
at what we got here and what drives this
change in the modern medicine actually
um
the role of bioinformatics in general in
the context of diseases is to allow
researchers to access to process and to
analyze
and and also to visualize several of
these kinds of high throughput
sequencing data that we will get
introduced to over the course of this
program and this program will also
introduce you to several examples of how
this connection between this mixed data
and their explanation or the reason
behind the diseases and their
effectiveness into several treatment
options was done successfully by
researchers studying for example viral
infections like Ebola virus outbreak in
West Africa we will also take examples
from covid-19 pandemic as well as we can
also study microbial pathogens causing
uh for example tuberculosis and
development of resistance to several of
the treatment options and antibiotic
that this tuberculosis encounters it to
we will also we can also consider cancer
and their responses to different
treatment therapeutic options that we
have and in the end we will also have
options to work with single cell
parasite that causes malaria so we will
briefly touch on viral genomics viral
Evolution and gene expression patterns
and detection of significant genomic
variants as well as some important
aspects of microbiome and Byron
community in a hosts that are being
studied to find important associations
of these several different omics data
with disease susceptibility and disease
outcomes as we move along
yeah my uh and animation is running slow
so
cancer I don't have to introduce all of
you to cancer cancer is the leading
cause of death worldwide and this
accounts for nearly one in six deaths
right some of the most common cancers as
we know are breast cancer lung cancer
colon cancer rectum cancer and prostate
cancer
causing infections are prevalent and
they are such as
papilloma virus and hepatitis virus or
responsibly responsible for
approximately 30 percentage of the
cancer cases in countries that are still
under developing or still developing
right so many of these cancers can be
cured if they are detected early and if
they are treated effectively and this is
where Precision medicine is applied to
enable early detection of cancer by
studying various different molecular
drivers in these tumor cells and in
these tissues that are responsible for
the for the tumerogenesis and for the
tumor progression
uh is this the case if somebody else can
confirm can you hear me
yes so we can hear you yeah could you
please check your speaker settings thank
you for your confirmation
so as we already spoke about cancer
cancer is one area where in Precision
medicine seems to be making significant
head away right a new therapists seek to
Target the specific cellular pathway
that is being exploited by cancer with
the view to make something like a short
life of tumor or with a view to make
intervention to the tumerogenesis and
the progression of this cancer
so that exists and urgent need to
identify new biomarkers or novel
signatures that will help us in early
detection and prognosis and new
biomarkers and signatures can be and are
in fact identified by leveraging
publicly available omix data resources
from the Cancer genomics Association or
tcga from ncbi resources and from
various other public resources which you
will get good introduction and good
um demonstration in this program to find
the data and to download the data and to
process and analyze the data so that we
can find some novel associations with a
disease progression
so the field behind this omics data
analysis is the big data bioinformatics
and this has developed tremendously in
the last several decades that
transformed life sciences and that
enabled bio biotechnology and also is
empowering biomedical research to a
completely new facet so as a result
there came many new discoveries from
researchers from analysis of existing
omics data that includes new treatment
that includes diagnostic assays that
design strategies for novel
experimentations that will confirm the
effects of these identified biomarkers
treatments and assets
so the main catalyst as we discussed for
the transformation of the biomedical
research is the emergence of sequencing
technology and in this program we will
introduce you to sequencing methods and
particularly Next Generation sequencing
methods or high throughput sequencing
technology that will help us study
genomic variations have genes and their
expression RNA transcripts and their
parts in the disease progression and how
all of these molecular elements are
linked to disease biology
so to give you a sense of how this
genomics data came into existence then
we already know that that is that it's
it's already been most 50 years since
the time of sequencing of the human
genome and in around 2015 the 1000
Genome Project brought significant
number of whole genome sequences to the
research Community for analysis and for
uh finding implications that 100 000
whole genomes were sequenced by 2018 and
today there exists or there there is an
ever increasing number of data sets that
are available to help researchers to
understand cellular processes to
understand molecular functions and in
the context of disease biology and in
the context of for example
um
rare diseases and also in the context of
cancer biology
so this growth of high throughput
sequencing data is largely driven by the
cheaper faster and more efficient
sequencing of Next Generation sequencing
or simply NGS right from around a
billion dollars in 2001 to around
approximately three million dollars in
2008 and by 2017 alone the cost of a
single sequence genome was close to 100
one thousand dollars and the aim is to
reach around less than 500 or 100
dollars by 2025 I believe if I'm after
all so this has put a tremendous amount
of tremendous volume of data that is
available genomic status that is
available which is driving the whole big
data bioinformatics uh
field false so
this technology like NGS can be used to
explore the rules the relationships and
the actions of various types of
molecules that make up the cells of an
organisms and many types of these omics
data can be generated using as we know
right the Next Generation sequence a
technology and we will also study or we
will also discuss in this program how
this data can show detailed information
about genomic variants and the patterns
of Gene and isoform expression and the
differences in the microbial communities
that drive the differences in the
disease biology
so the economics of this data are hugely
or extremely important for clinical
practice and translational approaches of
the implications that we can find and
associations that we can find so far
Medical Data as simply clinical data to
introduce you to is a type of
information that we have been using for
centuries right it's like measuring
temperature measuring heart rate
measuring blood pressure and other
symptomatic data that is on the surface
these are typically easily and quickly
measured or cheaply measured and are
covered appropriately by insurance but
with the Advent of molecular biology and
cellular biology and with the Next
Generation sequence of Technology we
have learned how health and diseases are
driven by what's happening but this
subcellular level or what's happening at
the
intercellular level and biomedical data
refers to the combination of all of
these omics data that characterizes the
subcellular level of the disease biology
with the clinical un relevant clinical
data that is happening at the surface
right
and these different omics data include
genomics proteomics and even microbiome
of a patient that can be related to in
the difference in which that these
microbial communities help us process
the metabolomics that we have in our
life
so to give you an example of one of
these omics data types and how they are
used and how they are how they actually
change the approach so as a method of
measuring RNA translation
transcriptomics data or transcriptomic
studies can actually help us detect mRNA
expression inside a cell as an accurate
alternative to measure membrane protein
expression which is actually used for
example traditionally to let's say to
characterize tumor histologically this
change in approach to focus on the
molecular Precision in a molecular level
actually changes the Precision in
improved Precision in Diagnostics and it
also enabled development of treatment
based on molecular Pathways instead of
observational chemistry or observational
characteristics of diseases specifically
tumor for example
so the classification of tumor itself
has changed or it's it actually uh
started to include molecular
classification in addition to
histological classification or
functional classification that one can
observe or that one can obtain
superficially and this includes for
example
uh classification at the level of
molecules with complex variation across
genomics and transcriptomics data and
also variation that will also include
risk profiling of the patients based on
the models that can be generated from
the data trends that we find from these
genomics transcriptomics proteomics and
even metabolomics data and to give you
an example in addition to the existing
Pam 50 classification and histological
falsification of breast cancer we now
have a separate set of molecular
classification for that characterizes
breast cancer in in terms of luminal a
or luminal b there's a like or normal
like the flooding low Etc so these are
also described or these are also
demonstrated to be extremely important
to classify as several of these
different classified subcategories react
differently or respond differently to
treatment options or therapeutic options
so the significance of the data that we
just discussed is huge as cancer can be
diagnosed earlier and the treatment can
be selected and adapted as the new data
is generated and the drug safety can be
monitored driven by the complex modeling
of the disease progression themselves
not based on The Superficial or not
based on the
um
what I'm looking for is a
response related data but it's based on
subcellular and system-wide data symptom
not based on the symptomatic data but
based on the sub-cellular molecular and
system work data that was what I was
looking